我这样婚姻我觉得我很糊涂，
我觉得我开一天，
我想要努力姐放申请一下，
我有时候看你直播，
我努力姐要是真是我的姐姐，
但是我自舅，
我平常没事儿陪他，
他句话我人生不至于男走到这样几步，
你说说吧，
你现在是啥情况，
我结婚五年，
然后现在分居两年，
男方现在的想法是想让我回去，
我在犹豫，
对姐因为我们，
那你跟我说一下，
你俩有小孩了吗？
啊，
5岁男孩女孩啊，
对呀，
女儿现在周一到周五我带着他，
然后周六周日叫爸爸接头，
当初你为什么要跟他爸爸分居啊，
我举一个事情啊，
就是我老公婚前七八十多个W，
然后我帮他还了有7个。
我这有三张借条啊，
我让他父母帮他还一部分，
然后他父母帮他还了几个，
可之后每个月再背着我的情况下，
问他儿子要3000，
这三天用来还他爸爸妈妈的，
觉得他在背着我做这件事情，
我不讯于我这个小家的成长的啊，
这是一件事情，
然后第二个事情就是他会不会应该骗了20多个都不回来，
成姐呀，
都是我个人呢，
我结婚的时候，
我怀孕生孩子的时候，
他跟我说一句话，
生孩子的前原因呢，
我们最划分，
这是一方面，
第二个方面我分析的因，
我觉得我很不舒服的解释。
我们结婚一两个月之后，
开始在外面各种花花世界，
那我问你啊，
当孩子的钱对半分的意思是说生孩子要花的这个钱，
你俩就是对半承担，
还是说生孩子收到的礼金你俩对半分，
生孩子住院钱对半分，
他说我们能不能对半分，
我家里没有钱，
我得记。
第二个就是生孩子，
李金茹公公婆婆到最后她钱拿走了，
大儿子本来恰又多钱就生孩子，
那个领金公婆又拿走，
导致我们肾机，
你的这个情况啊，
姐妹，
你跟她分居没毛病，
我我说这话我不怕被骂，
如果一个男人在一个女人生孩子的过程当中这么计较，
连生孩子的要出的这个钱，
他都想要女人来承担一半的话，
那这个男人心目中她对这个女人是没有怜爱的，
是一点爱都没有的，
一点联系都没有的，
她没有体察这个女人在怀孕生产过程当中要付出什么，
要经历什么，
要拿生命去冒这个风险去生孩子，
要拿自己的身体生健康去生这个孩子，
他对你没有一点怜爱，
跟他分居没毛病，
分了就分了，
你其实是想问我说龙菲姐，
我分的对不对是吧？
该不该跟他分居，
还要不要跟他复合？
那从我这个角度啊，
龙飞姐也算是阅人无数了，
如果一个男人在一个女人怀孕生产这个过程当中还这么计较，
还说钱你出一半，
我出一半的话，
他就该自己干着，
他就该自己过，
他就不该有老婆。
我们分期第二年的时候，
他现在还他的工资，
他一个月工资，
有了钱然后拿工资。
多5000，
他天天说你回来，
你回来了之后，
我把。
工资每个月存5000块钱，
重新再找一个男的，
如果这个男的顾家的话，
他也愿意把工资给你啊，
你就找一个愿意把工给你的不就得了吗？
嗯，
我害怕孩子给我，
我肯定是能养得起，
因为我本身一个月七八千块钱孩起我的，
我能养得起孩子，
但是他呀，
你也想要孩子，
我也想要孩子，
然后我自己了几个律生，
律师的意思是说，
嗯，
控制了孩子是就是反关系子，
就是直接就是说把孩子给他了，
就不会遇到那么多麻烦，
所以不想失去孩子，
我每次真到我如果孩子分礼物，
浑身都打颤，
我每次想到给我女儿分离，
你这事儿别那么着急，
你这事儿先拖着，
先拖着是什么意思呢？
你不是跟他分居了吗？
其实我们啊，
生过孩子的女人都会知道，
我跟一个男人分居的话，
对我来说好像没有任何的负面的这个影响，
我对他也没有什么想法，
也没有什么需求，
对吧？
但男人不一样，
他跟你分居时间长了吧，
他比较出的问题，
他总得找人，
什么时候等他找人了，
那面的人恨不得都怀孕了，
这个时候你跟他谈离婚，
你跟他谈孩子的抚养权，
好谈多了，
我明白你的意思了，
我们先家长先分家长，
那后面再说，
对。
哎，
然后孩子在你这儿的时候，
你要留足证据，
留足孩子在你身边的证据，
让孩子拍照啊，
孩子买东西的所有的记录啊，
都网上购买，
留下那个证据知道吗？
送孩子去哪玩啊，
带孩子去那游乐场啊，
带孩去公园啊，
带孩子去哪玩啊，
都要留照片，
留视频，
留证据，
就是叫你星趣不准妈，
我现在哎呀，
我现在怀孕了谁的。
谁的爸爸的叫老公呢？
怀孕几个月几个月，
那这事你别问我。
你要同样同样的火坑啊，
你不能跳两遍，
然后这一把在怀孕的时候，
他再要求你出一半的钱，
你心情能好吗？
姐妹，
你不能被人家拿捏一辈子啊，
你到时候有两个孩子了之后，
你更是手心手背都是肉，
有两个孩子要分手的话，
90%以上的概率是一人一个，
你到时候你说你要哪个，
你不要哪个，
人是很难改变的，
你要说你再生一个孩子，
他就改变了，
嗯，
他就不那么计较了，
他就心疼你了，
他就觉得你生孩子不容易了，
人是很难改变的。
也就是你现在要再生的话，
等于要把你上一场的那种痛苦再经历一遍，
现在我跟他沟通的是，
我不是现在也在租房子嘛，
我现在也没有房子啊，
就是让大家出一部分，
然后我自己出一分，
如果我买个房子，
然后这个房子归我个人，
你你觉得这样可以吗？
他不会的，
他最多我告诉你，
我如果是他，
我会怎么干，
好不先稳住你都答应你，
我一定改啊，
不是看房子还有一个过程吗的，
这个小区交通不好，
看到那个房子觉得那个房子没有那个什么好的小学，
看到这边就觉得，
哎哟，
这个地方到处候吵死了，
一直拖到你孩子4个月5个月。
然后。
你怎么办？
没错吧，
买房子哪有一蹴而就的，
买房子哪有去了就买的，
你以为是买白菜呢，
一到两个月的时候我都答应你，
答应的好好的，
我陪着你去看嘛，
看完了之后就说，
一，
这个地方旁边要建个垃圾场，
这个不好，
对身体不好，
看完了那个又说，
哎呀，
这个地方旁边哦，
那个小学啊，
教学质量差的很，
这个地方也不好，
我直接给你拖到五个月，
现在经济不景气，
现在买房子可能还要跌，
等跌了我们再买，
等孩子出生了我们再买，
你能怎么着？
弟姐他如果直接把现金给我呢？
给了婚姻协议，
他给你多少现金啊，
你会给我下一个40个。
我觉得也不划算，
你人一辈子啊，
你现在可能觉得三十万四十万，
觉得好大的钱，
人这一辈子啊，
就是他就算现在给你30万，
给你40万，
他到后面他又说这30万是我从银行贷款的，
这30万是我管我表姐借的，
这30万是我管我姐夫借的，
那还是夫妻共同的债务吗？
他自己本人，
他有这个能力吗？
对呀。
那你说吧。